I mean obviously your are you close with
your kids kids kids it extremely close
with their we're wondering everything
because there's a lot of time in your
life when you and al weren't close and
now you kind of like get along with this
girl he's wonderful he broke up with her
but yo it's it's all know we have a
spectacular friendship in fact I take
him more of my eye I tell him everything
does he live in town yeah yeah I tell
him everything I don't know if he tells
me everything but you know does he call
you yeah we talk all the time yes but
that's that that's different the last
couple years right no no no no not this
has been going on for a few years but
before that it was no talk right no it
was always talk but you know we kind of
went from like zoom loving each other
becoming parents hating each other
becoming friends and then best friend
and now you're back in the best friends
does he call you like little things like
you know Bev I don't know is this girl
as you start talking about her I got to
tell you something you know I have no
now 24 years and if you've noticed I'm I
may be the only person who's never
discussed my relationship with them and
I won't now it's really private
really I've told you a lot